part of it is that when you're exploring
your own genome it changes everything
you're suddenly incredibly interested in
and you overlook what could be the
statistical things that are trouble you
know hard for you to comprehend and it
just when you're looking at your own DNA
it's you kind of I think can get beyond
understanding what what exactly are
these risk profiles that I'm looking at
because you're so personally engaged in
it and Esther Dyson our board member
uses the analogy of baseball and
statistics if you talk about dry
statistics people just their eyes roll
in the back of their head and they don't
really they're not that interested but
when you take it to baseball suddenly
statistics kind of melts into the
background and now you're looking at at
the sport and how people are performing
and we see the same thing with genetics
that all the science kind of scary stuff
fades to the background and it's all
about you